[موسيقى]
إنه يوم 23 فبراير في جنوب غرب
ألبوكيرك في جيبسون وميسينا
حيث يبدأ الطلاب في الصعود من
الحافلة التي ركضوا بالقرب منهم لمساعدة الشرطة على القول إن
الرجل الذي تراه على الأرض هنا في
ذلك القميص الأحمر هو ماريو بيريز ، سائق سيارة
موستانج التي تحطمت  في الحافلة
المليئة بطلاب مدرسة جورج سانشيز
الإعدادية يصرخون من الألم وهم
يحاولون معالجة ما حدث للتو ، يبذل
الضباط قصارى جهدهم لتهدئتهم ، وكان
23 طالبًا على متنها في
الوقت الذي أصيب فيه اثنان بجروح خطيرة ، يمكنك
سماع سائق الحافلة والآخرين يحاولون ذلك
ساعدوا شخصًا مصابًا بكسر في الساق كانت
العائلات تشعر بالقلق أيضًا بشأن
أحبائهم ويعتقد المحققون أن بيريز كان
يسير أسرع من 110 أميال في الساعة في
وقت ما عندما اصطدم بالحافلة وتقول الشرطة
إنه كان ذاهبًا من 65 إلى 80 مما تسبب
في سقوط الحافلة على جانبها
عندما كنا  إبطاء هذا الفيديو ، يمكنك
رؤية الفرس يصطدم بتلك الحافلة